Stephen Bannon had an epic meltdown over
Trump's nft Trading Card grift you have
to see this video there are elements in
magoworld that are Furious about this
nft launch last week Trump teasing I'm
going to be making a major announcement
tomorrow and the announcement was that
you could buy digital trading cards of
scrumps in various outfits looking like
a superhero they should have had Trump
on the toilet at 3am posting to truth
social essential or Trump on The View
saying if Ivanka weren't my daughter I
would like to date her those would be
the interesting Trump trading cards
instead they were like Trump in a
Spider-Man outfit okay anyway Steve
Bannon can't believe it Steve Bannon
melts down and says what on who came up
with this disastrous idea now they're
called Trump digital trading cards okay
these cards feature some of these can't
do something
he's one of the greatest Presidents in
history but I got to tell you that's not
true whoever what business partner and
anybody in the comms team in anybody
marlago and I love the folks down there
but we're War they ought to be fired
today right you came out with something
that's so important which I still don't
think gets to the heart of it and hey
you don't have three harder cores than
Cortez Bannon and sub gorkers and we're
getting blown up we're the biggest
supporters and this is stupid they
understand walk me through it walk me
through your assessment of this sir yeah
never should have happened I I mean look
it's fun it's hyperbolic but whoever
wrote that that pitch should be fired
and should never be involved in any I
don't want them making Trump should be
fired and never be involved in politics
ever again the the presidential napkins
for Mar-A-Lago okay anybody who came up
with that and the president's War chest
is is pretty strong right now yes
because he claimed he was raising money
for 2022 candidates and he kept 80 of it
we've got two years until the actual you
know inauguration we don't have time to
waste if you want to do this kind of
stuff you know have have a peon do it
okay get get somebody who's recognized
in the Maga world to you know put their
face to this thing and do it yeah like
Seb Gorka or Steve Bannon right but the
President should not be involved with
this when we yeah so this was you know
Mega world was pretty split over the
stupid digital trading cards some of
them maybe they really like liked it but
at least they went along with it and
said this is amazing but Bannon and
Gorka couldn't do it now the there's a
lot of money laundering questions around
it the idea would be that you could
launder money through these nft trading
cards someone could potentially buy a
whole bunch of these digital trading
cards using illicit funds or funds that
they would like to really be
contributing to Trump's campaign but
they're in excess of the legal limits
for those contributions they could buy a
bunch of those cards and that would be a
way to funnel uh money to Donald Trump
you could also launder money personally
by buying a bunch of these cards with
illicit funds then at a later date
selling them and then it potentially
might be a way to clean that money for
the individual couple different ways
that you could actually use this to
launder but absolutely pathetic and
humiliating uh uh decision which
financially may have actually worked out
because they're claiming that the
trading cards sold out I I know it's
just all completely Bonkers but they're
claiming that they the grift worked that
they got 99 out of enough people
Maga people and I'm not going to redo it
but remember
cult members are overwhelmingly likely
to continue falling for the stuff the
cult leader says people who get scammed
are overwhelmingly likely to be scammed
again and again and again we've spoken
about why extensively uh won't redo that
here but it seems to be happening make
sure you're following the David Pacman
show on Instagram at davidpackman show
if you would like to see an incredible
heartwarming picture
of me with my daughter taking in the
Argentinian Men's National Team World
Cup win yesterday
check out my personal Instagram at
david.pakman it is uh it is a picture
that will bring a tear to your eye her
first World Cup and we got the win it's
incredible we'll take a quick break I
know many of you have said David sir
you've got to cover America Fest oh
believe me we're going to get to America
Fest after the break before you go if
you enjoyed this video and want to see
more please make sure to subscribe to my
YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description